vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění kvantové informaci a výpočtům, jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel pro vzdělávání v IBM
Quantum. Toto je 12. lekce série a zároveň poslední lekce třetí jednotky, která se věnuje obecné
formulaci kvantové informace. Tato lekce se soustředí na základní pojem kvantové informace, jímž je
purifikace kvantového stavu. Purifikace kvantového stavu reprezentovaného hustotní maticí je
čistý stav většího složeného systému, který nám po stopování zbytku složeného systému zanechá původní stav.
Každá hustotní matice má purifikaci a o kvantových stavech a kvantové informaci obecně se toho dá hodně naučit
studiem purifikací. Na intuitivní úrovni jsou kvantové stavové vektory reprezentující čisté stavy jednodušší matematické objekty než hustotní matice, a přemýšlením o
purifikacích stavů jsme schopni nahlížet na libovolné kvantové stavy systémů jako na pouhé části něčeho většího, ale
jednoduššího. Budeme také hovořit o věrnosti mezi dvěma kvantovými stavy, což je hodnota, která kvantifikuje jejich
podobnost či překryv, a která se často používá jako způsob měření toho, jak dobrý je konkrétní stav v porovnání s
nějakým ideálním stavem. Konkrétně budeme diskutovat definici věrnosti spolu s některými jejími základními vlastnostmi a uvidíme,
jak věrnost souvisí s purifikacemi. Zde je přehled lekce: začneme purifikacemi, včetně
definice a jednoduchého důkazu jejich existence, který nám říká, jak jednu najít, pokud ji potřebujeme. Pak budeme diskutovat něco známého
jako Schmidtův rozklad kvantového stavového vektoru dvou systémů a uvidíme, jak Schmidtovy rozklady souvisejí s
purifikacemi. Poté budeme diskutovat kriticky důležitý vztah mezi libovolnými dvěma purifikacemi stejného stavu, který je znám jako unitární
ekvivalence purifikací. A nakonec projdeme několik příkladů. Pak se obrátíme k věrnosti,
včetně její definice a některých základních vlastností. Budeme hovořit o lemmatu šetrného měření, což je velmi
užitečný fakt, který váže věrnost zpět na měření, a nakonec, abychom lekci uzavřeli, obrátíme se k Uhlmannovu teorému, který
stanoví fundamentální spojení mezi věrností a purifikacemi. Začněme s
definicí purifikace. Purifikace stavu, o němž předpokládáme, že je reprezentován hustotní
maticí, je čistý stav většího složeného systému, který nám zanechá původní stav, se kterým jsme začali, když je zbytek
složeného systému vystopován. Toto můžeme vyjádřit přesněji v matematických termínech
následovně: pokud máme systém X v nějakém stavu ró, přičemž ró je hustotní matice reprezentující stav X,
a S je kvantový stavový vektor páru systémů XY takový, že vystopování Y z čistého stavu zanechá
ró, pak říkáme, že S je purifikací ró. Přirozeně na názvech nezáleží,
systémy a stavy můžeme pojmenovat jakkoli a na pořadí systémů také nezáleží. Například,
pokud by byl systém Y vlevo místo vpravo, ale vše ostatní by bylo stejné, stále bychom se na S odkazovali jako na purifikaci ró. Ale
pro zbytek lekce se budeme držet hlavně tohoto nastavení jen kvůli jednoduchosti. A první věc, kterou je třeba říci
o definici, je, že purifikace vždy existují pro každou hustotní matici ró. Přesněji řečeno, každá hustotní
matice ró má purifikaci tak, jak popisuje definice, za předpokladu, že systém Y je alespoň tak velký jako X, tedy
Y má alespoň tolik klasických stavů jako X. Pojem purifikace a
fakt, že purifikace vždy existují, se ukázal být kriticky důležitý a je také součástí toho, co dělá kvantovou informaci krásnou, a doufám, že to
budu schopen dokázat do konce lekce. Teď dokažme, že každá hustotní matice má purifikaci, přičemž
v tomto procesu uvidíme, jak purifikaci získat, když ji potřebujeme. Stejně jako v definici
purifikace, předpokládejme, že X je systém a ró je hustotní matice reprezentující stav
X. Teď uvažme libovolné vyjádření ró jako konvexní kombinace čistých stavů, jak máme napsáno na obrazovce. Slovy,
pro nějakou volbu kladného celého čísla n máme pravděpodobnostní vektor p0 až pN mínus 1, stejně jako kvantové
stavové vektory ψ0 až ψ n mínus jedna, a průměrováním odpovídajících čistých stavů vážených pravděpodobnostmi
získáme ró. Například bychom mohli použít spektrální větu k získání takového vyjádření ró, a pokud bychom to udělali,
mohli bychom vzít n jako počet klasických stavů X. Ve skutečnosti bychom mohli vzít n jako hodnost ró, která je
rovna počtu nenulových vlastních hodnot ró, přičemž každou počítáme tolikrát, jaká je její násobnost, a
to nikdy není větší než počet klasických stavů X, ale může být menší. Na druhou stranu toto
nemusí být spektrální rozklad ró a tyto kvantové stavové vektory nemusejí být ortonormální. Například jakékoli takové vyjádření ró
je v pořádku. A zde je purifikace ró: součet probíhá přes stejné hodnoty jako
v našem vyjádření ró a uvnitř součtu bereme odmocniny pravděpodobností vynásobené ψ_a tensorovaným
s ket a. Mimochodem, předpokládáme, že 0 až n mínus jedna jsou klasické stavy druhého systému Y, takže
dává smysl, že S je kvantový stavový vektor páru XY, tak jako v definici. Ve skutečnosti zde není důležité,
abychom v tomto vyjádření použili standardní bázové stavy Y. Místo ket 0 až ket n mínus jedna bychom mohli dosadit jakoukoli ortonormální kolekci
stavů. A nyní můžeme ověřit, že toto je skutečně
purifikace, výpočtem parciální stopy přes Y. Zde je vyjádření stavu, který dostaneme provedením parciální stopy.
Stopa ket a bra b je buď jedna nebo nula podle toho, zda a je rovno b nebo ne, takže se výraz
zjednoduší na naše původní vyjádření ró. A je to tak jednoduché. Purifikaci tedy získáme velmi snadno, pokud máme dostatek klasických stavů Y, nebo alternativně dostatečně velkou ortonormální množinu k použití
namísto standardních bázových stavů ket 0 až ket n mínus jedna. A mimochodem, pokud je počet
klasických stavů Y menší než hodnost ró, pak purifikace neexistuje, a to nechám
na tvém zamyšlení, pokud se tak rozhodneš. Zde je příklad: uvažme
hustotní matici, kterou jsme několikrát viděli v lekci o hustotních maticích. Zde máme vyjádření této
hustotní matice jako konvexní kombinace čistých stavů. Není to spektrální rozklad, ale to
nás nezajímá. A s téměř nulovou námahou můžeme zapsat purifikaci stavu podle
receptu. To není jediná purifikace této hustotní matice, purifikace nejsou jedinečné, ale to je v pořádku.
Definice nic o jedinečnosti neříká, a ve skutečnosti existuje velmi zajímavý vztah mezi různými purifikacemi téhož stavu, ale
o tom budeme mluvit o něco později v lekci.
Definice nic o jedinečnosti neříká a ve skutečnosti existuje velmi zajímavý vztah mezi různými purifikacemi téhož stavu, ale
o tom si povíme trochu později v lekci. Dále se budeme zabývat Schmidtovými rozklady, což jsou vyjádření
bipartitních kvantových stavových vektorů v určité formě, kterou za okamžik popíšu. Jsou pojmenovány po Ervinu
Schmidtovi, stejném Schmidtovi, který je znám pro Gram-Schmidtův ortogonalizační postup, ale v případě Schmidtových rozkladů pravděpodobně
by po Schmidtovi pojmenovány být neměly. Je to matematicky ekvivalentní s něčím zvaným rozklad na singulární hodnoty pro matice, což je něco, co bylo
ve skutečnosti nezávisle znovuobjeveno vícekrát, ale to se stává. Každopádně, zde je to, co máme na mysli,
když hovoříme o Schmidtově rozkladu: pro libovolnou volbu kvantového stavového vektoru S páru
systémů XY je vždy možné zapsat S ve speciální formě. Tato forma je taková, jak
máme na obrazovce, kde R je nějaké kladné celé číslo, p0 až p r mínus jedna jsou kladná reálná čísla, která
dohromady tvoří pravděpodobnostní vektor, x0 až x r mínus jedna jsou jednotkové vektory odpovídající systému X a y0
až y r mínus jedna jsou jednotkové vektory odpovídající systému Y. To nemusí vypadat zvláště
speciálně, dokud neřeknu, že obě množiny x0 až x r mínus jedna a y0 až y r mínus jedna musejí být
ortonormální. Proč je to speciální? Kdybychom vybrali libovolnou bázi pro jeden ze dvou systémů, řekněme
vektory X odpovídající systému X, pak bychom vždy mohli vyjádřit S v této formě, ale to by nás donutilo
vybrat vektory Y určitým způsobem. Ve skutečnosti to děláme poměrně rutinně, stejně jako se standardní bází, kdy si
nastavujeme analýzu měření ve standardní bázi. Ale obecně, i když vybereme ortonormální bázi pro vektory X,
vektory Y, které dostaneme, nemusejí být ortonormální. Podobně, kdybychom si vybrali
ortonormální bázi pro vektory Y a pokusili se S vyjádřit v této formě, opět bychom mohli, ale vektory X by
nemusely být ortonormální. A nakonec, pokud bychom vybrali ortonormální vektory pro oba systémy a
pokusili se S vyjádřit v takové formě, nemuselo by to fungovat, protože bychom možná potřebovali zkřížené členy, ale v součtu je jen
jeden index a, takže forma je speciální, ale vždy je možné
zapsat daný jednotkový vektor S takto. A zde je postup: nejdříve spočítej spektrální rozklad
redukovaného stavu jednoho ze dvou systémů. Na tom nezáleží, ale pro popis postupu se podíváme na redukovaný stav
X, tedy stopujeme Y. To znamená, že p0 až p r mínus jedna jsou vlastní
hodnoty tohoto redukovaného stavu ró a x0 až x r mínus jedna jsou jednotkové vlastní vektory odpovídající těmto vlastním hodnotám. A
přičemž ignorujeme členy, pro něž jsou vlastní hodnoty nula, protože tyto členy nic nepřispívají
k součtu, to znamená, že p0 až p r mínus jedna jsou všechna kladná reálná čísla a R je počet nenulových
vlastních hodnot s násobností, což se rovná hodnosti ró. Takže to nám dá p0 až p r
mínus jedna a také x0 až x r mínus jedna. A vše, co zbývá, je najít vektory y0 až y r
mínus jedna. Existuje jen jedna možná volba, tyto vektory jsou v tomto bodě jednoznačně určeny a lze je
snadno najít pomocí jednoduchého vzorce zobrazeného na obrazovce. A co je úžasné je, že
pokud takto tyto vektory definujeme, jsou zaručeně ortonormální, a to nám dá Schmidtův rozklad. To v tomto
videu nebudu dokazovat, ale není to příliš obtížné a pro případ zájmu si můžeš přečíst psaný materiál k lekci.
Odkaz najdeš v popisu videa jako obvykle. Jako příklad uvažme tento
kvantový stavový vektor, který jsme získali jako purifikaci příkladu hustotní matice, ke kterému se opakovaně
vracíme. Není to Schmidtův rozklad, protože stav nula a stav plus nejsou ortonormální, ale lze jeden najít
pomocí postupu, který jsem právě popsal. Prvním krokem je výpočet spektrálního rozkladu redukovaného
stavu X, což je tentýž příklad hustotní matice, a zde je jeho spektrální rozklad, který jsme viděli
v lekci 9. Takže vybereme p0, P1, x0 a X1 tak, jak je
zobrazeno na obrazovce. p0 a P1 jsou vlastní hodnoty ró a x0 a X1 jsou
odpovídající jednotkové vlastní vektory. Zbývá tedy vypočítat y0 a y1, a pokud to uděláme, dostaneme ket plus
pro y0 a mínus 1 krát ket minus pro y1. To není okamžité, musíš
skutečně provést výpočet, abys to viděl, ale to je výsledek. A jak se očekávalo, tyto dva vektory jsou ortonormální,
jak tomu vždy bude, pokud jsi výpočty provedl správně. A to nám dává Schmidtův
rozklad. Schmidtovy rozklady jsou velmi užitečné v mnoha situacích a brzy uvidíme, co nám říkají
o purifikacích. Purifikace nejsou jedinečné. Daný kvantový stav reprezentovaný hustotní
maticí bude mít ve skutečnosti nekonečně mnoho purifikací. Existuje však úzký
vztah, který vždy platí mezi libovolnými dvěma purifikacemi téhož stavu, a někdy se nazývá unitární
ekvivalence purifikací. Zde je, jak to funguje: nechť ró je hustotní matice
reprezentující kvantový stav systému X a předpokládejme, že máme libovolné dvě purifikace tohoto stavu, které jsou
čisté stavy téhož složeného systému. Pro konkrétnost předpokládejme, že S a ψ
jsou kvantové stavové vektory páru systémů XY, přičemž oba nám dají ró, když je systém Y vystopován.
Co říká unitární ekvivalence purifikací, je, že musí existovat unitární operace U působící pouze na
systém Y, která transformuje S na ψ. Jinými slovy, i když jsou to
libovolné purifikace ró a o nich nepředpokládáme nic jiného než to, že obě purifikují ró a jsou
stavem téhož složeného systému XY, musejí být v jistém smyslu ekvivalentní, až na unitární operaci na Y
samotném. Uvidíme několik příkladů, které ilustrují, proč je to zajímavé a jaké důsledky to má, ale nejdříve
uvidíme, proč je to pravda. Začněme spektrálním rozkladem ró, což je
hustotní matice, kterou purifikují jak S, tak ψ. Stejně jako při diskusi Schmidtova rozkladu
budeme předpokládat, že jsme zahodili všechny členy odpovídající nulové vlastní hodnotě, takže p0 až p r mínus jedna
jsou všechna kladná reálná čísla, x0 až x r mínus jedna jsou ortonormální vlastní vektory ró a R je
hodnost ró. A mimochodem, jen jako poznámka na okraj: všimni si, jak často v tomto bodě saháme po spektrálním teorému.
Je to neuvěřitelně užitečný nástroj a bez něj bychom byli ztraceni. Každopádně, nyní když máme spektrální
rozklad ró, můžeme vypočítat Schmidtovy rozklady našich dvou vektorů, stejně jako předtím, a budou
téměř totožné. Koeficienty a vektory X jsou stejné, protože pocházejí ze spektrálního rozkladu redukovaného stavu, který
je stejný pro oba vektory. Jediný rozdíl je v tom, že pro druhý systém můžeme dostat různé vektory. Pro
první vektor, což je S, dostaneme jednu sadu vektorů y0 až y r mínus jedna, a pro druhý vektor ψ dostaneme
možná odlišnou kolekci, kterou můžeme nazvat z0 až z r mínus jedna. Takže nyní máme Schmidtovy rozklady
našich dvou vektorů, které vypadají velmi podobně, až na to, že vektory pro druhý systém mohou být různé. Ale to jsou
Schmidtovy rozklady, takže obě kolekce jsou ortonormální. Můžeme tedy jednoduše zvolit
unitární matici U, která posílá y_a na z_a pro každé a. To vždy lze, protože unitární
operace jsou ve skutečnosti ekvivalentní lineárním zobrazením, která transformují jednu ortonormální bázi na druhou, a pokud
tyto dvě množiny nepokrývají celý prostor odpovídající Y, vždy je lze obě rozšířit na ortonormální
báze pomocí, mimochodem, Gram-Schmidtova ortogonalizačního postupu. A takto se dokazuje unitární
ekvivalence purifikací. V lekci 4 série jsme probírali protokol superdenzního kódování,
který umožňuje odesílateli přenést dva klasické bity příjemci odesláním jednoho qubit za cenu jednoho ebitu
sdíleného provázání. Předpokládám tedy, že tento protokol již znáš, a smyslem tohoto příkladu je stručně
vysvětlit, jak souvisí s unitární ekvivalencí purifikací. Pamatuj, že způsob fungování
protokolu spočívá v tom, že Alice a Bob sdílejí ebit, neboli jinak řečeno stav Bell ψ plus. Alice se rozhodne transformovat tento
Bellův stav na libovolný ze čtyř Bellových stavů v závislosti na dvou bitech, které chce poslat, a pak pošle svůj
qubit Bobovi, který měří, aby zjistil, který Bellův stav má. Všimni si, že všechny čtyři Bellovy stavy
nám dávají stejný redukovaný stav Bobova qubit, což je úplně smíšený stav, a to je vlastně již dostačující
k závěru, že superdenzní kódování je možné. Všechny čtyři Bellovy stavy purifikují úplně smíšený stav, takže z unitární
ekvivalence purifikací víme, že musí být možné, aby Alice transformovala stav Bell ψ plus na
libovolný jiný aplikací nějaké unitární operace na svůj qubit. Samozřejmě není obtížné vymyslet unitární operace, které
skutečně fungují a jsou velmi jednoduché, ale je přesto zajímavé, že k tomuto závěru lze dospět
bez přemýšlení o samotných unitárních operacích. A navíc můžeme dospět k závěru,
že zobecnění superdenzního kódování na větší systémy jsou možná, za předpokladu, že máme způsob, jak zobecnit Bellovy stavy na větší
systémy tak, aby všechny dávaly úplně smíšený stav jako Bobův redukovaný stav. A ve skutečnosti existují různé známé způsoby, jak to udělat.
Jiný kontext, ve kterém má unitární ekvivalence purifikací důsledky, je kvantová
kryptografie a jedním z jejích nejdůležitějších důsledků je, že vylučuje existenci bezpodmínečně bezpečného kvantového protokolu pro
kryptografický primitiv známý jako bit commitment. Co tedy bit commitment je? Bit commitment je příklad
kryptografického primitivu, čímž myslíme nízkoúrovňový úkol nebo proceduru poskytující základní funkcionalitu, která
pak může být použita jako stavební blok pro zajímavější věci, jako je tvorba schémat digitálního podpisu nebo budování
protokolů nulového znalostního dokazování. Například v případě bit commitmrnt je základní funkcionalitou, že
jeden hráč Alice je schopna závazně sdělit binární hodnotu své volby druhému hráči Bobovi, ale její volba zůstává skrytá
až do té doby, než se ji rozhodne odhalit. Od protokolu implementujícího bit commitment
požadujeme dvě specifické vlastnosti: musí být závazný, což znamená, že Alice nemůže změnit názor poté, co se k bitu zavázala, a
musí být skrývající, což znamená, že Bob nemůže zjistit Alicin bit, dokud ho nezvolí odhalit.
Bylo by tedy pěkné, kdybychom mohli tento primitiv implementovat pomocí kvantové informace, protože je to
užitečný primitiv, ale bez dalších předpokladů se ukazuje, že to nelze provést dokonale pomocí kvantové informace, ani přibližně dokonale,
a unitární ekvivalence purifikací odhaluje, proč: základní myšlenka na velmi vysoké úrovni je taková,
že pokud by existoval kvantový protokol pro bit commitment, musel by existovat takzvaná purifikovaná verze tohoto protokolu, kde si představíme, že
Alice má systém A, Bob má systém B, a po provedení závazku, ale před Aliciným odhalením, je pár AB v
jednom ze dvou čistých stavů ψ0 nebo ψ1 v závislosti na bitu, ke kterému se Alice
zavázala. Pokud je protokol dokonale skrývající, pak musí platit, že Bob nemůže rozeznat rozdíl mezi
dvěma závazky, takže jeho redukovaný stav musí být stejný pro obě možnosti. To ale implikuje, na základě
unitární ekvivalence purifikací, že Alice může transformovat jeden stav na druhý aplikací nějaké unitární
operace na A samotné. Protokol tedy zcela selhal jako závazný. Existují detaily, které jsem
zametl pod koberec, ale podstata věci je taková, že unitární ekvivalence purifikací nám říká, že tento primitiv není něco,
co bychom mohli spolehlivě implementovat pomocí kvantové informace bez dalších předpokladů určitého
druhu. Posledním příkladem důsledku unitární ekvivalence purifikací je teorém známý jako
Hughstonův-Jozsův-Woodsův teorém neboli teorém HJW. Začněme samotným tvrzením
teorému, přičemž se jedná o trochu zjednodušenou verzi jen proto, abychom se vyhnuli technikalitám a zaměřili se na hlavní
myšlenky. Předpokládejme, že X a Y jsou systémy a ψ je libovolný kvantový stavový vektor reprezentující čistý stav páru
XY. Nyní předpokládejme, že uvažujeme redukovaný stav samotného systému X a přijdeme s libovolným způsobem, jak
vyjádřit tento redukovaný stav jako konvexní kombinaci čistých stavů, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce.
Například počet N v tomto vyjádření, což je počet čistých stavů, přes které průměrujeme, může být
libovolně velký, možná mnohem větší než dimenze prostoru odpovídajícího X nebo Y.
A co nám teorém říká, je, že musí existovat měření na systému Y s N výsledky, přičemž
nastane následující: když je systém Y změřen, za prvé každý výsledek měření
nastane s pravděpodobností přesně rovnou odpovídající pravděpodobnosti v našem vyjádření redukovaného stavu X jako
konvexní kombinace čistých stavů, a za druhé, podmíněno na získání určitého výsledku měření,
stav X se stane odpovídajícím čistým stavem z konvexní kombinace. Proč je to
zajímavé? Znamená to totiž, že pro jakýkoli způsob přemýšlení o redukovaném stavu X jako o konvexní
kombinaci čistých stavů existuje nějaké měření Y, které efektivně přemění tento způsob přemýšlení o redukovaném stavu X
na realitu. A co je pozoruhodné, je to, že to je možné i tehdy, když je stav ψ vybrán nejdříve a konvexní
kombinace je vybrána až poté, pokud je to vyjádření redukovaného stavu X, vždy bude existovat
měření Y, které funguje přesně takto. Podívejme se tedy, jak to dokázat.
Začneme dvěma různými vyjádřeními redukovaného stavu X, který budeme pro přehlednost nazývat ró.
Dále zavedeme nový systém Z, jehož klasické stavy jsou možné výsledky měření, neboli
ekvivalentně indexy v naší konvexní kombinaci. A nyní můžeme pozorovat, že následující dva kvantové stavové vektory
γ0 a γ1, které jsou oba stavovými vektory složeného systému XYZ, jsou
oběma purifikacemi ró. Aby bylo jasno, když uvažujeme o těchto vektorech jako purifikacích ró, myslíme
systémy Y a Z dohromady jako jediný složený systém, který je vystopován, aby zanechal
ró. První vektor γ0 je v podstatě totéž jako původní čistý stav ψ, kromě toho, že
inicializujeme nový systém Z do stavu nula. Je jasné, že pokud vystopujeme Y a Z, zbude nám ró, takže γ0
je purifikací ró. Druhý vektor γ1 je v podstatě vektor, který dostaneme purifikací
ró na základě konvexní kombinace, jak jsem popisoval dříve v lekci. Tentokrát je systém Y
inicializován, a pro jednoduchost předpokládám, že nula je klasickým stavem Y, ale mohl bys dosadit libovolný
standardní bázový stav, nebo ve skutečnosti libovolný čistý stav Y do tohoto vyjádření a nezměnilo by to nic. V každém případě, vystopování Y a
Z nám opět zanechá ró, takže pointa je, že toto jsou obě purifikace ró, a proto, na základě
unitární ekvivalence purifikací, existuje unitární operace U na páru YZ, která transformuje γ0 na
γ1. A to vše potřebujeme k popisu měření, které dělá to, co teorém
říká. Jednoduchý způsob, jak ho popsat, je pomocí diagramu circuit, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Slovy, začínáme
stavem ψ, zavedeme Z inicializovaný do stavu nula, provedeme U a pak změříme horní systém, což je Z,
měřením ve standardní bázi. Efektivně to transformuje ψ na γ1 a
pouhým pohledem na popis γ1 vidíme, že to dělá to, co teorém říká, totiž že dostaneme
každý výsledek a s pravděpodobností p_a a podmíněno na získání a zůstane systém X ve stavu ψ_a.
A aby bylo jasno, samotné měření, jehož existenci teorém implikuje, je implementováno
vším v tečkovaném obdélníku na obrázku. A pokud chceš vědět, jak lze
měření popsat jako kolekci matic, zde je jejich vyjádření. Tuto část nebudu vysvětlovat a pro účely příkladu to
není důležité, ale to je vyjádření matic měření pro případ, že tě to zajímá.
Dále budeme diskutovat věrnost, což je míra toho, jak podobné jsou dva kvantové stavy, nebo alternativně, jak
moc se překrývají. Začneme definicí, která na první pohled může vypadat trochu záhadně,
ale odhalíme ji, a doufám, že do konce diskuse tě přesvědčím, že je to
ve skutečnosti mnohem hezčí funkce, než by se na první pohled zdálo. A zde je
definice: věrnost mezi dvěma hustotními maticemi ró a σ se rovná stopě druhé odmocniny z výrazu odmocnina z ró krát σ krát odmocnina z ró. Budeme o tom
mluvit nejdříve, pojďme jen pochopit samotnou definici. Máme tři odmocniny a
všechny se vztahují k odmocnině z pozitivně semidefinitní matice, což je, jak jsme probírali v předchozí lekci,
jedinečná pozitivně semidefinitní matice, jejíž čtverec nám dá libovolnou matici, ze které odmocninu bereme. Protože
ró je hustotní matice, musí být pozitivně semidefinitní, takže z ní můžeme odmocninu vzít, a pokud uvažujeme výraz odmocnina z ró krát
σ krát odmocnina z ró, vidíme, že je také pozitivně semidefinitní, a konkrétně ho lze zapsat jako
M† krát M pro M rovné odmocnině z σ krát odmocnině z ró, a proto z něj lze odmocninu vzít.
Konkrétně můžeme spočítat spektrální rozklad výrazu odmocnina z ró krát σ krát odmocnina z ró, a pak
k výpočtu odmocniny stačí vzít odmocniny vlastních hodnot
a nechat vlastní vektory beze změny. A nakonec vezmeme stopu této
matice, a protože stopa se rovná součtu vlastních hodnot, dostaneme výraz, který máme právě
zde. Takže to asi nechceš obecně počítat ručně, a toto vysvětlení možná nenabídne velký
vhled do věrnosti nebo proč nás zajímá, ale doufejme, že objasní technický
smysl vzorce. Mimochodem, jen jako poznámka na okraj, někdy lidé definují věrnost jako
čtverec funkce, kterou jsem právě definoval, a tuto funkci pak nazývají odmocninová
věrnost. Uvidíš ji definovanou oběma způsoby, což má potenciál způsobit zmatek, ale obvykle to nezpůsobuje,
protože lidé bývají obecně docela pečliví ohledně toho, která definice se používá, a ty bys měl
dělat totéž. Pro mé oko neexistuje správná nebo špatná definice. Definuji to
takto jednoduše proto, že jsem si zvykl to takto dělat a shledávám to o trochu pohodlnějším, myslím proto, že bych raději
něco umocnil než brát odmocninu přídavně, když nastane potřeba, ale samozřejmě je na tobě, jak se rozhodneš.
Každopádně, vraťme se k věrnosti tak, jak je zde definována. Existují i jiné ekvivalentní způsoby,
jak věrnost definovat, a je to vlastně docela pozoruhodná funkce v tomto ohledu, a lze ji charakterizovat i docela zajímavými
způsoby. Zde je poměrně přímočarý způsob, jak přepsat definici v termínech stopové normy, kterou jsme viděli ke konci
předchozí lekce. Do stopové normy jsem nezacházel příliš do detailu, a konkrétně jsem ji
nedefinoval ani pro nehermitovské matice, ale má dost jednoduchou definici. Jedním způsobem, jak definovat stopovou normu
libovolné matice M, je, že je to stopa z druhé odmocniny M krát M† nebo ekvivalentně stopa z druhé odmocniny
libovolné matice M je stopa z odmocniny M krát M†, nebo ekvivalentně stopa z odmocniny
M† krát M. Oběma způsoby dostaneš stejnou hodnotu a tuto definici lze použít ke zjednodušení
definice věrnosti, jak máme dole na obrazovce, a to je hezké, protože odhaluje, že
je symetrická v obou argumentech. Stopovou normu čtvercové matice M lze také vyjádřit jako
maximum absolutní hodnoty stopy M krát U přes všechny unitární matice U, což není zřejmé, ale je to
pravda, a to nám dá další vyjádření věrnosti. Takže zde máme tři
ekvivalentní definice věrnosti, a to je jen začátek. Existuje několik dalších ekvivalentních definic a
uvidíme jednu zvláště důležitou, která pochází z Uhlmannova teorému, ke konci lekce.
Dobře, to je hezké, ale co to vše znamená na intuitivní úrovni a proč by nás tato
funkce měla zajímat? K zodpovězení těchto otázek je užitečné uvažovat speciální případ, ve kterém alespoň jedna ze dvou hustotních
matic reprezentuje čistý stav. Pokud jsou oba stavy čisté, pak je
věrnost jednoduše absolutní hodnota vnitřního součinu dvou kvantových stavových vektorů, a v jistém smyslu je to
hlavní motivací věrnosti samotné. Absolutní hodnota vnitřního součinu dvou kvantových stavových
vektorů je vždy číslo mezi nulou a jednou a dává nám přirozený způsob měření toho, jak moc se
dva kvantové stavové vektory překrývají. A věrnost si lze představit jako užitečný a dobře chovající se způsob, jak
rozšířit tento způsob měření překryvu z čistých stavů na hustotní matice. Pokud je jeden ze stavů čistý
a druhý nemusí být, pak opět máme jednoduchý výraz pro věrnost, který může být dost
užitečný, a tento výraz je zobrazen přímo zde. Věrnost má mnoho zajímavých
vlastností, a to je jeden z důvodů, proč ji lidé používají. Má definici, která není zrovna
příliš hezká, ale přesto je to velmi užitečná funkce, a často se s ní velmi snadno pracuje díky jejím mnoha
úžasným vlastnostem. Podívejme se tedy na některé z nich, počínaje pozorováním, že věrnost mezi dvěma hustotními
maticemi je vždy číslo mezi 0 a jednou. Je nulová tehdy a jen tehdy, jsou-li stavy
ortogonální, což znamená, že obrazy jsou ortogonální podprostory, nebo ekvivalentně, že součin dvou matic je
nulový. A věrnost je jedna tehdy a jen tehdy, jsou-li si obě hustotní matice rovny. Každý jiný případ je někde
mezi tím, ale intuitivně řečeno, čím blíže je věrnost jedné, tím jsou si stavy podobnější, nebo alternativně,
tím více se překrývají. Věrnost je také symetrická, zmínil jsem to před chvílí, je to
poměrně zřejmé z vyjádření věrnosti pomocí stopové normy, ale přesto je to důležité si uvědomit.
Dále je věrnost multiplikativní pro produktové stavy, což znamená, že věrnost mezi dvěma
produktovými stavy je vždy rovna součinu věrností mezi jednotlivými
stavy. Zde je velmi užitečná vlastnost: pokud máme libovolné dvě hustotní matice stejné velikosti
spolu s libovolným kanálem, který bere tyto hustotní matice jako vstup, věrnost může po aplikaci kanálu
na oba stavy jen narůst. Jinými slovy, z hlediska věrnosti mohou kanály stavy jen
přiblížit k sobě, ale ne oddalovat. A nakonec, alespoň pro tento seznam,
existuje poměrně úzký vztah mezi věrností a vzdáleností stopy mezi stavy, která je definována
jako polovina stopové normy rozdílu dvou hustotních matic. Vzdálenost stopy mezi dvěma
stavy úzce souvisí s tím, jak dobře je od sebe rozlišíme, což jsme diskutovali v předchozí lekci v kontextu
diskriminace stavů a Helstromova-Holevoova teorému, zatímco věrnost kvantifikuje, jak moc se dva stavy
překrývají. Přestože tedy nejde o totéž, není překvapivé, že mezi těmito
dvěma veličinami existuje vztah. V každém případě tyto nerovnosti, které se typicky nazývají Fuchsovy-van de Graafovy nerovnosti,
tento vztah matematicky zpřesňují, a je docela důležité, že zde absolutně nezáleží na velikosti systému, o kterém mluvíme.
Tento vztah vidíme o trochu jasněji s pomocí obrázku. Pokud máme dva stavy a
vzdálenost stopy mezi nimi umístíme na osu x a věrnost na osu y, pak odpovídající vertikální
a horizontální přímky musejí se protínat někde uvnitř šedé oblasti. Nejzajímavější oblastí
grafu je, alespoň z praktického hlediska, levý horní roh šedé oblasti. Konkrétně, když je
vzdálenost stopy velmi malá, věrnost musí být velmi blízká jedné, a naopak.
Tyto nerovnosti se používají velmi často, a část důvodu pro to je, že nás nakonec záleží více na
vzdálenosti stopy, protože má přirozenu interpretaci ve spojení s diskriminací kvantových stavů,
ale věrnost má tolik úžasných vlastností, že se obecně s ní pracuje snadněji, a pokud jsme v levém horním rohu
šedé oblasti, kde se velmi často nacházíme, příliš neztrácíme převodem tam a zpět mezi věrností a vzdáleností stopy. To jsou tedy
některé vlastnosti věrnosti. Je toho mnohem víc, ale je to dobrý začátek a doufám, že seznam
pomůže při rozvoji intuice o věrnosti. Zde je hezký příklad toho, jak
můžeme věrnost propojit s nedestruktivními měřeními. Je to velmi užitečný fakt, známý jako lemma šetrného měření.
Předpokládejme, že máme systém X, stav X reprezentovaný hustotní maticí ró a měření na systému X
popsané kolekcí pozitivně semidefinitních matic. Předpokládejme, že jeden z výsledků měření je velmi pravděpodobný,
pokud bychom měření na stavu ró provedli. Pro jednoduchost předpokládejme,
že je to výsledek nula, který je velmi pravděpodobný, a konkrétně předpokládejme, že tento výsledek nastane s
pravděpodobností větší než 1 mínus epsilon pro nějakou malou hodnotu epsilon, kterou nemusíme konkrétně specifikovat. Epsilon
je jen malé kladné reálné číslo. Nyní jsme popsali naše měření, jako by šlo o destruktivní
měření, ale víme z předchozí lekce, že toto měření bychom mohli implementovat nedestruktivním způsobem, a konkrétně to bychom mohli udělat tak,
jak jsme viděli v naší diskusi Neumarkova teorému, a to funguje takto: každý výsledek a nastane s
pravděpodobností rovnou stopě P_a krát ró a podmíněno na získání tohoto výsledku se stav X změní.
Konkrétně v případě, že dostaneme pravděpodobný výsledek nula, se stav stane odmocninou P0 krát ró krát odmocninou P0,
vše normalizováno tak, abychom dostali hustotní matici. A co nám lemma šetrného měření říká, je, že v tomto případě,
tedy že skutečně dostaneme pravděpodobný výsledek měření, se stav, který získáme, příliš nezměnil od
původního. A konkrétně čtverec věrnosti bude nutně větší než 1 mínus
epsilon. A to je skvělé, protože je to zcela obecné. Neřekli jsme nic o měření nebo
stavu kromě toho, že jeden z výsledků je velmi pravděpodobný. Lemma lze tedy aplikovat v
mnoha různých situacích, kde chceme ověřit něco o kvantovém stavu, aniž bychom ho příliš narušili. Podívejme se tedy, jak to
dokázat. Z větší části jde ve skutečnosti o poměrně jednoduchou záležitost výpočtu věrnosti mezi stavem před a po měření.
Můžeme to udělat pomocí původní definice a normálně by nám to mohlo ponechat nepřehledný vzorec, ale
v tomto případě máme štěstí, protože výraz uvnitř vnější odmocniny je ve skutečnosti čtverec matice, která
se ukáže být pozitivně semidefinitní, což učiní výpočet odmocniny triviálním. Nyní můžeme použít cyklickou
vlastnost stopy spolu s linearitou stopy ke zjednodušení výrazu, jak je zobrazeno na obrazovce. Všimni si mimochodem, že to jsou
všechno rovnosti, takže jsme v tomto bodě nic nepřibližovali, opravdu jen zjednodušujeme. Ale nyní potřebujeme
nerovnost, protože bychom se rádi zbavili odmocniny v čitateli, a to skutečně můžeme udělat, pokud se spokojíme s dolní mezí. Pokud
tě zajímají detaily pro tuto část, nerovnost poměrně snadno získáš uvažováním spektrálního rozkladu P0.
Vlastní hodnoty P0 musejí být mezi 0 a jednou, to vždy platí pro matice popisující
měření, a jakmile to víme, nerovnost poměrně přímo plyne ze skutečnosti, že vzít odmocninu čísla
mezi 0 a jednou ho může jen zvětšit. Jiný způsob, jak to říci, je, že umocnit číslo mezi nulou a
jednou ho může jen zmenšit. Nyní lze trochu dále zjednodušit a dostaneme odmocninu
ze stopy P0 krát ró. Nakonec umocněním obou stran a
dosazením naší meze na pravděpodobnost dostaneme, co chceme. Vzorec pro věrnost tedy
není nejhezčí ani nejsnadněji použitelný na světě, ale zde skutečně funguje poměrně
hezky. Na závěr lekce se podíváme na Uhlmannův teorém, který je základním faktem o věrnosti, jenž
ji spojuje s pojmem purifikace. Co teorém říká jednoduše: věrnost mezi libovolnými dvěma
kvantovými stavy se rovná maximálnímu vnitřnímu součinu v absolutní hodnotě mezi dvěma purifikacemi těchto
stavů. Podrobněji: předpokládejme, že ró a σ jsou hustotní matice pro nějaký systém X, a předpokládejme, že Y je
systém, který má alespoň tolik klasických stavů jako X, takže je zaručeno, že oba tyto stavy mají purifikace, které jsou
kvantovými stavovými vektory XY. Pak můžeme vyjádřit implikaci teorému ve formě rovnice
zobrazené na obrazovce: věrnost mezi ró a σ se rovná maximální absolutní hodnotě vnitřního součinu
mezi ψ a S přes všechny ψ a S, které purifikují ró a σ
příslušně. Vyčistěme tedy to a pracujme s přesným matematickým tvrzením. Nyní teorém dokážeme,
ale nejdříve stojí za to ocenit, že nám nabízí poměrně intuitivní způsob přemýšlení o
věrnosti. Je také samo o sobě docela užitečné, například pro dokazování ještě zajímavějších věcí o
věrnosti. K důkazu začneme spektrálními rozklady našich hustotních
matic. Žádné překvapení. Jakmile máme spektrální rozklady, je snadné vymyslet
dvě konkrétní purifikace těchto stavů. Ale zde ve skutečnosti zahrajeme
trik. Všimni si, že v obou případech nemáme standardní bázový vektor jako druhý tensorový faktor, jak jsme měli dříve v
lekci, ale spíše stejný vektor jako v prvním tensorovém faktoru, ale s pruhem nad ním. To
znamená po složkách komplexně sdružený z těchto vektorů. Jinými slovy, v podstatě jen bereme
druhou kopii vlastních vektorů, ale bereme komplexně sdružené každé složky, a uvidíme proč to za chvíli
děláme. Není to vůbec zřejmé, proč to dělat, a proto to nazýváme
trikem. V každém případě, to jsou purifikace ró a σ příslušně, a to platí z důvodu,
že naše vlastní vektory jsou ortonormální, a proto i jejich po složkách komplexně sdružené jsou ortonormální. A nyní můžeme aplikovat
unitární ekvivalenci purifikací, která říká, že každou purifikaci našich dvou stavů lze získat
aplikací unitární operace na systém, který je vystopován. Pro konkrétní volby purifikací, které
jsme právě provedli, unitární operace nemusejí být stejné pro obě purifikace.
Samozřejmě, takže zde používáme písmeno U pro první a písmeno V pro druhou.
Pointa tedy je, že každou purifikaci našich dvou stavů lze zapsat, jak máme na obrazovce, pro
nějakou volbu unitárních operací U a V. A nyní můžeme vzít výraz
z teorému a zjednodušit ho. Pokud dosadíme naše vyjádření pro ψ a S a trochu zjednodušíme,
dostaneme výraz zobrazený na obrazovce. Je tam několik kroků, které jsem neukázal podrobně,
takže víš, co dělat, pokud to chceš provést. Ale zmiňuji, že důvod, proč jsme zvolili purifikace, jak jsme zvolili,
byl ten, aby se tento vnitřní součin zjednodušil přesně tímto způsobem, a konkrétně jsme tam vložili komplexní sdružené,
abychom efektivně mohli přehodit vnitřní součiny ve druhém tensorovém faktoru a dostat specifickou
formu, kterou máme právě zde. Jsme téměř hotovi. Nyní můžeme použít cyklickou vlastnost stopy spolu
s spektrálními rozklady, se kterými jsme začali, abychom dostali tento výraz, a v tomto bodě můžeme
využít jeden z alternativních způsobů vyjádření věrnosti pomocí stopové normy, a jsme
hotovi. Samozřejmě existují detaily, přes které jsem přešel velmi rychle, a je to druh důkazu, který
skutečně musíš sám projít, abys ho plně pochopil, ale doufám, že ti to dá základní
myšlenku. A jako obvykle najdeš více detailů v písemném obsahu k lekci, na který je odkaz v popisu videa.
A to je konec lekce, která byla o purifikacích, věrnosti a souvislostech mezi nimi. Je to také
konec jednotky, která byla o obecné formulaci kvantové informace. Doufám, že se ke mně přidáš na
čtvrté a poslední jednotce série, která pojednává o kvantové korekci chyb. Děkuji za sledování.